huang dan just paid with a new type of
money at this pharmacy
that's because china's paper cash is
going digital
the digital you want is meant to be
faster than using credit or debit cards
on digital wallets like apple pay
plus there are other incentives like
zero transaction fees for merchants and
one day it'll even work offline
but one major difference is that the
digital you want is 100 trackable by
china's central bank
and when it's launched nationwide it
could impact not only citizens but also
foreign companies operating in the
country
the central bank will know who's paying
how much they're paying
when they're paying where they're paying
and then to analyze
the patterns of payment china's central
bank has also said it plans to gradually
replace
all cash and coins with the digital yuan
the country would be the first major
economy to introduce a digital currency
in the real world
and while many users say the digital
yuan is easy to use
china's money revolution could usher in
privacy concerns
using the phone to pay isn't a new
concept for huang since he's one of
about 770 million mobile payment users
in china
who rely on digital wallets like and
groups alipay and 10 cents wechat pay
these private tech firms hold data on
transactions which the government can
access
but because the digital yuan is
developed by the central bank
there are no third parties and that data
sits with the government
to begin testing the digital currency
online and in physical stores
last year the chinese central bank
started doling out digital cash through
public lotteries in cities across china
huang is one of the 750 000 people who
have won some piece of the 23 million
dollar prize in the past year
to start spending his 30 dollars worth
of winnings huang first downloaded the
digital yuan app
yeah it recorded that he spent money on
lunch and medicine one saturday
afternoon in the southwestern city of
chengdu
about ten thousand merchants in chengdu
have signed up to accept digital yuan
zhongjang manages a dumpling restaurant
and she said the digital yuan has some
advantages compared with other payment
options
for instance two of china's most popular
digital wallets
charge merchants an average of 0.6 for
every transaction
there's also another upside in the works
the central bank is planning to make
transactions possible
even without an internet connection so
restaurants like zhong's won't have to
worry about their spotty connections
that sometimes make it hard to process
digital transactions
this digital yuan is less about money
and more about data yaya fanuci is an
adjunct senior fellow at the nonprofit
think tank
center for a new american security in
washington d.c
he's been studying digital currencies
for the past six years
and he says china's new currency is not
as anonymous as it claims
central bank has talked about there
being controllable anonymity which
really means
it's anonymous horizontally right the
users that are using it don't
necessarily know the identity of
everyone that they're interacting with
but
vertically it's not anonymous the
central bank is at the top with
information on all the users
china's central bank has promised to
protect users privacy
for now people can choose whether they
want to use the digital currency
but the central bank has said that as
the country becomes a cashless society
it expects the digital yuan to become
the primary way to make transactions
the chinese government could force
chinese companies
to only accept payment in digital yuan
which would then force the foreign
companies their foreign counterparts for
trade
it could ensure that they have to use
that central banks have authority to
control money supply
but their actions to restrict a digital
currency would have a more immediate
effect
leaving companies holding that currency
all the more vulnerable
for example fanuci says china's central
bank could put an expiration date on the
digital money
similar to how lottery winnings have to
be spent before a certain date
it means that the chinese government
could set up a whole lot of things to
have your currency
maybe valid or invalid based on its own
priorities
this is almost like handing over the
keys to your business
or to your finance department in some
ways because you really can't control
what at the end of the day may happen
with the the funds that you're holding
while there are privacy concerns fanuci
says digital currencies can create more
efficient monetary policy
and counter criminal activities china's
central bank said its digital yuan
system
would help combat money laundering
gambling and terrorism financing
meanwhile the central bank is also
looking into ways to make international
transactions possible in digital yuan
and fanuci says there's a big variable
that'll determine if that's going to
work
will foreign governments allow their
businesses and citizens
to to hold digital yuan and use it
it's not a given that all other
countries are going to transact
with this and will because of the
privacy the data issues
so this is really to be determined
while there's no set date for a national
rollout some officials have said the
digital currency could be ready for
wider use next february during the 2022
winter olympics in beijing
i think there is an element of showing
off for the big uh
for the big international audience we
have a central bank digital currency
that we're using we're the only country
the biggest country that's doing it
and china isn't alone in this experiment
according to one survey of central banks
86 percent of them from the u.s to japan
are exploring these types of currencies
for early digital yuan winners like
huang he says the trial went smoothly
and if the currency does go mainstream
he expects the surveillance aspect will
matter less to him
foreign